russian forces are stepping up their
offensive to take territory in the
eastern region of donbass kiev says the
main city still under ukrainian control
severo donetsk is coming under heavy
bombardment a local governor accused
moscow of engaging in a scorched earth
approach and intentionally trying to
destroy the city
in kiev the polish president has become
the first foreign leader to address the
country's parliament in person since the
war
began show of wartime solidarity between
neighbours
polish president anja duda became the
first foreign leader to speak to the
ukrainian parliament in person since the
war began
duda stressed his support for ukraine's
bids to join the eu and said that any
territorial concessions to russia would
be a blow for the entire western world
i want to say clearly
only ukraine has the right to decide its
future
there can be no negotiations and
decision-making behind ukraine's back
nothing can be decided about ukraine
without ukraine absolutely not this is
an iron principle
[Applause]
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
has said that only a diplomatic solution
will bring a definitive end to the
conflict but the government in kiev has
repeated it will not accept any
ceasefire that would require giving up
territory
on the battlefield russia's offensive to
capture the donbass grinds on with
shelling continuing along the front line
russian forces have intensified their
efforts to surround severo donetsk the
main city still held by ukraine in the
luhansk province
with fierce fighting raging across the
donbas neither side looks ready to
accept a compromise just yet
ndw's max sander joins me now from kiev
max the fighting in donbass has shifted
to the city of savara donetsk in recent
days ukraine is struggling to hold on to
it could that city become another
mariupol
right terry so analysts and military
experts have been voicing concerns over
the last couple of days that we would
see some more intense fighting along the
front lines in the donbass region the uh
industrial region of the southeast of
ukraine and this appears to have been
particularly true in and around the city
of seville dogs
where we've seen some intensive shelling
some air strikes and according to the
ukrainian military attempt by the
russian forces to take neighboring towns
in order to continue their assault on
the city which according to the
ukrainian military has not succeeded so
at the moment it doesn't seem that any
side is making any particular land gains
the russians are meeting fierce
resistance by the ukrainian side but the
situation in the town or in the city
itself is is dire as we can imagine
seville donetsk had about a hundred
thousand inhabitants prior to the war
and from what we're hearing there's at
the moment just one hospital in
operation with three doctors taking care
of the population of the entire city so
we can imagine the situation there is
deteriorating as we speak
tell us max why is siberia donette so
important for the russians
well the city
is important um
one of the reasons is that
in the first stages of the invasion um
russia tried to take to take kiev to
take the entire country
that was out of reach of moscow there
was a this was a military
not a success so they tried to um chip
away at other parts of the country and
the turn shift their focus south east to
the the regions held by russian
state-backed rebels and in particular in
the regions done uh in donetsk
province's donesk and luhansk and uh
seville donetsk is one of the last
remaining cities
in
the luhansk province that is in control
by the ukrainians so uh taking this town
for the russians would mean that they
would take uh the entire almost the
entire province and that they would have
control over that area and that would
bring them closer to their acclaimed
goals that they uh announced at this uh
the second stage in in later stages of
the invasion
what about the local residents there in
spirit donetsk
you mentioned that before the war there
were around a hundred thousand people
there
are many of them still left there
that is very hard to tell
what exactly is happening there at the
moment how many people have stayed but
this morning a police report was issued
that there had been a shelling of
residential buildings and an elderly man
was hurt and had to be brought to the
hospital so there are people still
living there
the luhan's governor sergey heidi said
that
russia was intentionally trying to
destroy the city and was applying a
tactic of scorched earth and that brings
us back to this mario pole comparison
this is something that we've seen
by russian forces done in chechnya in
syria and yeah we can imagine that the
people
and in mario paul
and we can imagine the people left in
the city
for them the situation is
unbearable
max thank you very much our
correspondent max sander there in kiev
frank ludwig is our regular military
analyst and joins me now from oxford in
the uk frank russia says it now controls
95
of luhansk province in ukraine is that
the case and if so how significant is
this development
well good morning terry i suppose it
depends on what one means by control
since there is
a intense battle going on as your
reporter said earlier around that city
of severo donetsk and its twin city
leschansk which is just just alongside
it
uh control would be the wrong word so
the russians are moving to surround that
city we will see over the next weeks
something like what happened in
mariappol
the difference is that
sivera donetsk is prepared for this as
mario paul wasn't
ukrainian ukrainian's been fortifying it
now for about seven years they knew
exactly what was going to happen
it's very reasonable to assume it was
going to happen and it has
and this will be a very very tough fight
however that said they are moving to
surround it they are making incremental
gains the russians and uh this battle
will go on for some time
okay so there's that battle that's uh
shaping up to be quite significant uh
what beyond that do you think is the
next step that the russian military is
likely to take in ukraine
well terry it's interesting that you
mentioned earlier that the russians have
claimed to control 95 percent of of uh
luhans province
one wonders whether that is now the
limit of their operational objective
it looks like it at the moment in
addition to what they've already gained
in the west around herself and my apple
of course and what of course they lost
around kharkiv
so what we can expect is
what's happened we got a little bit of
this from putin's speech a couple of
weeks ago it's very much a narrowing of
those objectives
uh
and focusing now on on that area with an
artillery
artillery-centred battle that's where
we're going now
so do you see an end game shaping up uh
in any of this frank
it was interesting as well wasn't it
president zielenski talked about or has
talked about the last few days is this
being the final stage of the war of
course it isn't
and what we could say i suppose it's the
end of the beginning and we're seeing
the rest of the war which could go on
for months or years
taking shape with the decisive battles
or the or the battles in any way
predominantly taking place down in this
southeast quadrant of the country which
we've known for some time
and unless negotiations are going to
intrude and there's no evidence that
they are ukraine has already said that
it will not accept anything short of the
recovery of its territory this war of
course is going to to grind on
in the short to medium term we're going
to see a big battle around siberia
donetsk the russians cannot sustain this
limited very limited momentum they are
achieving
and we will see things start to settle
down into something that looks like
status within the next few weeks
certainly i think before
the end of july middle of july
frank thank you very much for your
assessment that was frank ludwig
military analyst talking to us from
oxford
thank you terry
well russia has been accused of
committing war crimes during its
invasion of ukraine since the war began
its forces have targeted homes schools
and hospitals the scale of the
atrocities only becomes clear in areas
liberated by ukrainian forces dw's
matias berlinga went to one village in
the east where russian soldiers have
recently been forced out
a life in ruins switlana axionava has
just returned to what was her home
i can't say anything
a shell hit her house two days ago
this is what is left now we have nowhere
to come back to
people living here a message scribbled
on the door when the russian troops
arrived this village was occupied in the
very beginning of the war the russians
were here for two months and just three
weeks ago the ukrainians took it back
silana says that during those two months
she didn't even see the russian soldiers
that's because the fighting was so heavy
she never left her basement
the last night was the worst we thought
this is it
the house will collapse above us and
bury us in the basement our pets were
with us a dog and a cat
i came here to get the cat but i can't
find it
after the ukrainian army reclaimed the
village almost all inhabitants left for
the city of kharkiv as the fighting
continues
the russian positions are just beyond
the next village five kilometers away
most likely the shell that hit her house
came from there
if it doesn't collapse and isn't hit
again maybe we can come back and rebuild
it but i told my husband i would even
live in the basement as long as it is
home
for now she will go back to the city and
wait for the fighting in the area to end
the war in ukraine is also likely to
dominate the agenda of the world
economic forum getting underway in davos
switzerland today ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky will give the opening
speech by a video link we'll carry that
live for you in about two hours time
this year there will be no russian
delegation and in another snub a
ukrainian businessman is using moscow's
former residents in davos to stage an
exhibition on reported russian war
crimes in ukraine
this used to be the russia house here at
the world economic forum
now it's been re-christened the russian
war crimes house a ukrainian billionaire
is backing the project to highlight
alleged abuses committed by russian
troops in ukraine
the world economic forum caught all ties
with russia for this year's summit
meanwhile davos is rolling out the red
carpet for the biggest delegation from
ukraine ever president zielinski will
open the meeting with a video address
and for ukrainians here it's a
bittersweet moment
we are here in this beautiful setting
but at the back of our mind always
are these images of these horrific
killings and atrocities and war crimes
going on as we speak
back in ukraine and
we are here to as best as possible
represent those people and to do all
that we can to galvanize the
international community to support
ukraine even more
despite davos's spring cheer the mood is
somber amid soaring geopolitical
tensions the war in ukraine has worsened
the global food and energy crisis and
there are other urgent problems to
tackle as well
climate change the ongoing pandemic and
fears of an economic slowdown
the challenges are so big that we need
the support and the ideas of everyone
around the world so i think this is a
place where people trust each other and
we can build solutions together well
davos is a global convener of the
global decision makers i'm hoping that
it will really be able to facilitate
engagement because we are all for a
peaceful world
and we are all for
global prosperity
ukrainians have more immediate concerns
i don't think that we will see any you
know additional
pledges being made here in terms of
financial weaponry aid or something of
that sort to ukraine but i hope that we
can also use uh reach out to um business
community here and have them on board
also uh giving up on some of the
revenues that they were probably looking
for
with russian federation
it's now up to the global elite here in
the swiss alps to see if there's an
economic path to peace in the war in
ukraine
you